BRIAN: SHE HAS A FOLDER ON THIS
STUFF, DIDN’T SHE?
STEVE: THANK YOU, PETERS.
LET’S BRING IN REPUBLICAN
ARKANSAS SENATOR TOM COTTON.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
STEVE: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
FACT.
PETER JUST MENTIONED THIS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS TAKING
THE EXTRAORDINARY MEASURE OF
SENDING OUT WORD TO ANY FEDERAL
EMPLOYEE HEY, HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO LEAVE THAT BORING JOB IN
WASHINGTON AND COME DOWN TO OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER FOR 120 DAYS
BECAUSE IT’S ALL MESSED UP DOWN
HERE?
>> WELL, I WAS THERE LAST WEEK
AND WHAT I SAW WAS AN ABSOLUTE
CRISIS.
THESE THINGS ARE HEART-BREAKING,
OF COURSE.
YOU HAVE YOUNG MOMS AND DADS
WITH SMALL CHILDREN SITTING
UNDER A BRIDGE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT WAITING TO BE
PROCESSED.
INSIDE SOME OF THESE FACILITIES
YOU HAVE SMALL CHILDREN WITHOUT
EVEN PARENTS THERE ARE WHO ARE
SLEEPING RIGHT NEXT TO EACH
OTHER IN LARGE, I GUESS YOU
MIGHT CALL THEM CAGES, GUYS.
THEY REPLACED THE CHAIN LINKED
FENCE WITH PLASTIC WALLS.
BUT, STILL THEY ARE PACKED IN
TIGHT.
BUT ALL OF THAT ALL OF THAT
STEVE, IS ADDRESSING THE
SYMPTOMS NOT THE CAUSE.
ASKING FEDERAL EMPLOYEES TO
DEPLOY TO THE BORDER IS
ADDRESSING THE SYMPTOMS, NOT THE
CAUSE.
THE CAUSE IS JOE BIDEN OPENING
OUR BORDER AND SAYING ANYONE WHO
COMES HERE CAN GET IN.
ESPECIALLY ANYONE WHO HAS A
CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF 18.
WELL, GUESS WHAT YOU GET?
TENS OF THOUSANDS AND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS MORE OF?
PEOPLE SHOWING UP WITH YOUNG
KIDS.
I SPOKE TO SEVERAL OF THEM ON
FRIDAY NIGHT.
OR THURSDAY NIGHT UNDERNEATH
THAT BRIDGE.
AND I ASKED THEM WHY THEY CAME?
ALMOST TO A PERSON THEY SAID TO
FIND A JOB OR TO GET A BETTER
LIFE.
THEY DIDN’T SAY THEY WERE FACING
PERSECUTION BECAUSE OF THEIR
RACE OR ETHNICITY OR SEX OR
POLITICAL VIEWS OR RELIGION.
THEY CAME BECAUSE THEY WANT A
BETTER LIFE.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT’S NOT
BASIS FOR ASYLUM UNDER OUR
COUNTRY’S LAWS.
THEY ARE COMING BECAUSE JOE
BIDEN DISMANTLED THE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE POLICIES OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY COULD REINSTITUTE ALL OF
THOSE TODAY.
THEY COULD SAY WE ARE GOING TO
TURN BACK EVERYONE WHO COMES TO
THE BORDER BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
THEY CAN SAY YOU HAVE TO
ADJUDICATE YOUR ASYLUM CLAIMS IN
THE FIRST COUNTRY YOU ENTER
AFTER YOU LEFT YOUR COUNTRY MOST
LIKELY GAWT.
IF YOU GET TO THE BORDER, YOU
HAVE TO REMAIN IN MEXICO.
ALL OF THOSE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
POLICIES AND NOT A SINGLE ONE
RESULTED IN KIDS OR EVEN ADULTS
BEING TURNED THAT THE MEXICAN
DESERT AS HE AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION LIED.
THEY PUT THEM BACK ON PLANES AND
SENT THEM HOME.
AFTER YOU SEND THEM BACK HOME ON
ONE PLANE AND NEIGHBORS AND
COUNTRY MEN SEE THAT GUESS WHAT
IN THE REST OF THEM STOP COMING.
AINSLEY: SENATOR TED CRUZ WAS ON
THAT TRIP WITH YOU.
HE WAS AT A FACILITY IN DONNA, I
THINK IT WAS DONNA, TEXAS.
AND STAFFER CAME UP TO HIM AND
SAID YOU NEED TO PUT DOWN YOUR
PHONE YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
RECORD.
THIS WATCH THIS.
>> YOU DON’T WANT THE PICTURES
TAKEN, THE RULES ARE ARBITRARY
AND THEY ARE DESIGNED.
>> GIVE THE PEOPLE DIGNITY AND
RESPECT.
THAT’S ALL WE ASK.
>> WELL, NO, IT’S NOT.
YOU ARE -- IS THIS DIGNITY AND
RESPECT.
>> PLEASE GIVE DIGNITY AND
RESPECT TO THE PEOPLE I ASK YOU.
>> THERE IS A PANDEMIC.
>> I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU, SIR.
WITH FULL HEARTED.
>> DISRESPECTING THE RIGHTS.
>> FULL HEARTED I ASK YOU PLEASE
RESPECT THE PEOPLE.
>> ARE YOU RESPECTING THE RIGHTS
FOR THE KIDS.
>> THIS IS NOT A ZOO, SIR.
PLEASE RESPECT THE RIGHTS OF THE
PEOPLE.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT THIS IS A
DANGEROUS PLACE.
>> TRIED TO HIDE THEM.
I UNDERSTAND YOU ARE INSTRUCTED
WHEN 18 SENATORS CAME DOWN HERE.
>> RESPECT THE PEOPLE.
>> I RESPECT THEM AND I WANT TO
FIX THIS SITUATION.
>> WE ALL WANT TO FIX, THIS SIR.
WE DON’T WANT THIS TO HAPPEN
ANYMORE.
>> RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
CONDITION.
AINSLEY: SENATOR, TELL US WHAT
YOU EXPERIENCED?
WHAT’S GOING ON IN THAT VIDEO?
>> I SAW THE SAME THING.
THIS LITTLE POLITICAL WORKED TWO
WEEKS.
TRIED TO TOLD SULLIVAN IT ESCORT
OUT OF THE FACILITY I WONDERED
WHO IS GOING TO DA THAT.
THE BORDER PATROL AGREES THAT
JOE BIDEN’S POLICY UTTER AND
TODDLE TOTAL FAILURE.
THAT’S THE THING WE CONSISTENTLY
HEARD.
IS IF YOU LET THEM IN, MORE WILL
COME.
NOT SHOCKINGLY IF YOU SAY THAT
MINORS GET INTO THE COUNTRY OR
THAT ANYONE WHO SHOWS UP WITH A
CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF 6 GETS
INTO THE COUNTRY, GUESS WHAT?
YOU GET MORE IN THIS COUNTRY IT.
LEADS TO THE HEART BREAKING
SCENES THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
PICTURES AND VIDEOS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES.
AGAIN, THOSE ARE ALL JUST THE
SYMPTOMS NOT THE CAUSE.
THE CAUSE IS LETTING THEM INTO
THE COUNTRY IN THE FIRST PLACE.
ONCE THEY ARE IN, THEY WILL
NEVER GO HOME.
MANY OF THEM ARE NOT EVEN
GETTING A NOTICE TO APPEAR IN
COURT.
IF THEY DO APPEAR IN COURT, AND
THEY GET A NOTICE OF REMOVAL
DEPORTATION, JOE BIDEN HAS
HALTED DEPORTATIONS.
THESE PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY CAN
GET INTO OUR COUNTRY AND THEY
ARE NEVER GOING TO HAVE TO GO
HOME AND LEAD A BETTER LIFE.
THAT IS THE ULTIMATE FAILURE OF
OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
IT COULD ALL BE SOLVED BY SIMPLY
SAYING YOU CANNOT GET.
IN DO NOT COME.
IF YOU DO WE WILL SEND YOU HOME.
BRIAN: YOU DON’T HAVE A BIG
HEART WHEN YOU SAY EVERY
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR GETS TO
STAY.
YOU HAVE -- I THINK YOU ARE NOT
THINKING THIS THROUGH.
BECAUSE IF EVERY KID COMES, WHAT
ABOUT THE KIDS THAT ARE HERE?
WE DON’T EXACTLY HAVE A SOCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT NOW OVERRUN
WITH CASH.
WE ARE $27 TRILLION IN DEBT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF FOSTER KIDS
THAT NEED HOMES, WE HAVE A LOT
OF KIDS THAT NEED TO BE ADOPTED.
WHY ARE WE TAKING IN FOUR
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES AND I WILL
BRING SOMETHING ELSE UP?
THEY MADE TWO RIDICULOUS
STATEMENTS.
JOE BIDEN SAYS HE REPLACED A
LIGHT ON A CITY BLOCK AND HE
STOPPED GANGS IN CENTRAL
AMERICA.
REMEMBER THAT FROM THURSDAY.
AND THEN YESTERDAY KATE
BETTINGFIELD SAID WE ARE GOING
TO PUT MONEY INTO OPENING UP
BOYS CLUBS IN THESE TRIANGLE
COUNTRIES.
THAT’S RIGHT, THEY ARE HERE
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO BOYS CLUBS.
THAT’S REALLY GOING TO MAKE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS.
MAYBE CAN PLAY INTRAMULLER
BASKETBALL OR TAG THAT WILL
REALLY STEM.
THIS SOME OF THE THINGS THEY ARE
SAYING IS FARCICAL AND NEVER
PRESSED ON THEM.
>> ARE, BRIAN.
LET’S LOOK AT THE FACTS, AS
WELL.
THAT’S COUNTRIES LIKE GUATEMALA,
EL SALVADOR AND HONDURAS.
THEY ARE NOT HEAVEN ON EARTH.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PLACES IN
THOSE COUNTRIES THAT ARE SAFE.
YOU HAVE A FIRST DUTY IF YOU
WANT TO SEEK ASYLUM IS TO SEEK
IT WITHIN YOUR OWN COUNTRY.
MOVE TO A SAFER PART OF YOUR OWN
COUNTRY.
THOSE COUNTRIES AS A WHOLE HAVE
LOWER MURDER RATES THAN SOME OF
OUR CITIES LIKE BALTIMORE.
SO THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE CLAIMING
THEY WANT TO COME HERE AND SEEK
ASYLUM HAVE NO BASIS UNDER OUR
LAW TO SEEK ASYLUM.
JUST BECAUSE YOUR COUNTRY HAS
VIOLENCE OR POORER THAN THE
UNITED STATES DOESN’T GIVE YOU A
BASIS TO COME HERE.
YOU HAVE TO BE THE VICTIM OF
SISSATIC PERSECUTION FOR THINGS
LIKE RELIGIOUS YOU HAVE AS OR
POLITICAL VIEWS RACE OR SEX.
NOT A SINGLE ONE WITH WHOM I
SPOKE CLAIMED THAT THE OTHER
NIGHT.
THEY ALL WERE RESPONDING TO JOE
BIDEN AND TO HIS DECISIONS TO
ALLOW THEM IN.
AND IF WE LET THEM, IN MORE WILL
COME BY THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS.
BRIAN: THEY ARE COMING.
>> IT’S GOING TO COST
HARD-WORKING TAXPAYERS BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
IT’S GOING TO PUT NOT JUST OUR